Welcome to "English in a Minute."
If you have ever heard American English, you have probably heard this before:...
"I'm a jack of all trades."
This expression can tell you a lot about a person in American English.
It means a person can do anything.
So what do you do for a living?
I'm a handywoman.
I fix and replace just about anything, from computers to shower drains.
I guess you could say I'm a jack of all trades.
Basically, when you say "jack of all trades" in a conversation,...
...it's another way to say that someone has many professional talents.
You may also hear this phrase used: "Jack of all trades, master of none."
It was used to describe people who learned how to do a lot of different things.
But they weren't able to focus on doing one thing correctly.
And that's "English in a Minute."